Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa.
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Ruffians!
Today, today, well... Thank you for joining us today for our 49th episode!
49!
That's impressive.
Thank you, Ruffians.
49 episodes, 49 mornings together with you.
It's today.
It's today, yeah.
Well, for Ruffians joining us for the first time today, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short-format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
A.k.a.
FUWAMOCO-e.
And is hosted by us,
FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Another morning.
Hashtag, hashtag.
Ruffians, you don't have to say it like that.
We've gone over this.
Now you're just being silly, huh?
FUWAMOCO-chan.
Ruffians, you've been keeping your eyes open for Pero.
I think.
Have you?
Well, it seems like we have another Pero sighting!
Where is he this time, huh?
Not in Florida anymore.
Let's see.
De-den!
Orange!
I see a very cute, long, orange cat!
Cute cat vision.
Oh yeah, Pero's in the image.
He's there, hi.
I see, Pero is the root of all your problems.
All the darkness, huh?
Yeah, sounds familiar.
Shit feels like that for us too, huh?
For the darkness in our lives sometimes.
But it helps to have somebody to blame on the bad things, huh?
Yeah.
Just blame Pero for it all.
Yeah, just blame Pero.
But it looks like you have a good electrician on the job.
Why?
On your hands.
Actually, Ruffians!
Do we ever tell you?
Do you know how Pero feels towards cats, Ruffians?
I wonder, do we?
Do we?
No.
No, no.
Ruffians, you know that we really, really, really love cats, right?
Just a bit, just a bit, right?
But Pero, he's...
He's terrified of them.
Petrified.
He's rather approving of our desire to love and kiss and love and kiss and eat cats.
It's nice that he gives us the room to do so.
He doesn't want to be around for that.
We're enjoying cats, pero
He's not, he's not there.
He's gone.
It's nice to have that kind of room that time.
But just us on the cat.
But, you know, we're very confident that the electrician you have there will get the job done in no time, right?
That's probably why Pero's making that face, right?
He sees what's below him.
Doesn't like it, no.
Perified, right?
Perified.
Perified of cats.
Yes.
Well, hopefully you have light again soon.
Yeah, I'm sure it's just a couple little cat punches here.
A paw away.
BAU BAU!
I wish we had that kind of electrician, too.
I need the number.
The number?
Oh, the phone number?
Yes.
I would like a recommendation.
Thank you.
Right?
They can go change the lightbulb.
Right!
That would be good.
Ruffians!
You know, we had something very very happy we decided to share with you.
But I think you know, you might have heard.
Might have heard about it because
We just released a brand new cover song for Twitter Day over the weekend!
The song is Kanaria's "Identity"!
Yeah, it's our first VOCALOID song that we've ever covered.
Right?
What do you think, Ruffians?
You listen?
You like it?
Well, even if he didn't say, it sure seems like it.
Some Ruffians have been listening to it lots, right?
Thank you, Ruffians!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Mama, we talked a bunch about why we picked it, and our feelings about recording it, and the actual meaning and concept of the song.
It's surprising.
I guess also with our interpretation.
So if you listen to our cover, enjoy it!
We'd love if you also check out our afterparty for it.
The afterparty that we had.
We talked a lot.
Don't worry.
I recommend
Thank you, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
Moco-chan, do you have a way to... I recommend you listen to it like this, right?
Maybe with a cup of tea.
I don't know, maybe it's not a type of cup of tea.
Really?
I don't think so.
I was going to recommend headphones and maybe wear an iPad at the same time.
As a recommendation.
Headphones and an eyepatch, okay?
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
Wow!
Not just identity, but I think, you know, it's been an especially happy time for those who love hololive English and music, too!
Yeah, because, you know, the happiness continues because Gura-senpai had a new song released that's written and produced by THE HONEYWAY!
THE HONEYWAY!
It's BAU BAU!
This song is part of the whole honey project that's going on right now.
And it's called Tokyo Wabi Sabi Lullaby.
Tokyo Wabi Sabi Lullaby.
Wabi Sabi Lullaby.
How am I?
I thought you were supposed to be good at this, huh?
Not this one.
Wobby, wobby, wobby.
I'd like to see Gura-senpai try.
Challenge!
Yeah.
Formal request of a challenge.
Yeah, but this song, you know, it's very melancholic and even a bit of a sad song too, you know.
Reminding us just how hard it is to say goodbye to a good friend sometimes.
But, you know, it's really emotional.
The video and animation is also really beautiful too!
It's so nice.
We really love the cool city pop vibe of the song.
And you can tell that they put a lot of love and thought into making it.
And make it fit for Gura-senpai and her beautiful voice too.
It feels very different than the usual Sound of Honey like songs.
But we really really like it.
It might just be our favorite song by FUWAMOCO.
Right, right.
What do you think, Ruffian?
Very true.
I like it a lot.
It's very unique, right?
Right.
Yeah.
And you know...
There's also a very special challenge going on right now, where if you make a short video and upload it to YouTube or TikTok, you can receive a special original wallpaper.
Yeah, you just have to use the audio.
Right!
But there's only 10 people who get this special wallpaper, so if you have your eye on that prize, please enter!
Maybe we should enter something first.
Ruffians!
We also hit another milestone!
Another milestone!
Not FUWAMOCO Morning number 50.
That's not today.
Not yet.
Today is number 49.
But we wanted to say a big thank you for 400,000 listens on Cute na Kanojo!
Thank you!
We're so so happy!
So happy!
You know,
I hope that maybe there was more than a few new Ruffians who maybe first met us thanks to this cover song.
Right!
They might kind of think, oh, this FUWAMOCO's kind of cool.
Kind of something else.
Something else!
Right, we're kind of a different FUWAMOCO here, right?
I think maybe a lot of Ruffians think, ah, FUWAMOCO's something else, huh?
Right.
But yeah, it was really really fun to sing.
It's a very special cover to us too.
We hope that we'll be able to show lots of different sides of us.
The cool side.
The something else side.
More in the future.
More sides.
We want to release more music.
Thank you Ruffians!
BAU!
I'm pretty excited about this.
We kind of went out of our way.
Kind of.
So, we'll be in these BAU BAU lots of missions with you, okay?
BAU BAU!
No.
Although those are cool, too.
Those are cool, too.
BAU BAU!
A lot of listening to music.
A lot of minutes.
A lot of FUWAMOCO.
But!
Actually, we woke up to an amazing present today!
A well-known animator and hololive fan, 2Snacks, released a really cute animation today!
Of us!
It's really cute, it's really silly.
It's amazing!
I really love the fluid motion of everything and how the world within Spooky's Jumpscare Mansion was captured.
We laughed a lot watching it.
Yeah!
How dare you making us laugh straight from when we wake up, huh?
Right!
How dare you!
Oh my gosh, I was not- I was not ready for that, no.
I wasn't ready.
No, but Atsushi-sensei has done a lot of animations that we've seen of our senpai before, so we-
Do you understand?
Do you understand, Ruffians?
Do you understand what I'm feeling?
Yeah, it's hard to put into words.
But, you know, with this most recent one, even though it was really only just a few months ago that we made a debut.
Right, right.
But it takes us back, you know, to when we had just debuted.
Right!
And we're still just getting to know you, Ruffians, and it makes us feel really warm and fuzzy, too.
Yeah, go check it out!
Okay!
Thank you so much for the precious challenges!
We're sure she's going to love it too!
She'll think it's funny if you laugh too, right?
She'll be like, what's FUWAMOCO up to now?
BAU BAU!
Please tell us your reaction.
Okay.
Okay, I'm probably going to be like, that's so silly, but... I don't know.
It has been a little while, right?
There's a lot of milestones going on.
But there was another milestone that we hit.
And we didn't even realize it.
Not at all.
Ah, well.
You know, there's one Ruffian- Actually, there's a couple Ruffians that are very strong at this.
One Ruffian in particular is very strong at counting, has been counting every time we say BAU BAU since our debut.
Every BAU BAU!
What do you think of that, Ruffian?
That's a lot of words.
That's a lot, right?
But they've been hitting a counter every time!
Yeah.
But!
Together we just broke 100,000 BAU BAUS!
That's a lot of BAU BAUS!
Moco-chan, do you think you can get 100 BAU BAUS right now?
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU
I had 61,555 BAU BAUs, Moco-chan!
41301 BAU BAUs.
The bigger sister with the bigger BAU BAUs.
I wonder how much time that we've spent just BAU BAUing alone though.
Makes you think.
That would surely be BAU time though.
Thank you so much for calculating with me!
Maybe you don't need to count anymore.
Unless that's fun for you.
Unless it's fun, you know.
Everyone has their own idea of what's fun, you know.
It's kind of different maybe from each Ruffian to each Ruffian.
So, you know, we're really glad that you found yours and that we can protect your smile this way too.
Yeah!
You keep counting!
If that's fun for you.
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Maybe one day I'll become good at counting too.
I think it's gone.
Since it's over 20, it's whiskey.
It's what?
Whiskey.
Wow.
It's been a bit of a misunderstanding.
Yeah.
Kind of on that note maybe.
Kind of a misunderstanding.
I don't know.
Is it though?
Just a bit.
Right?
And we've told you before that it's our dog accents kind of coming through sometimes.
But we've been seeing more and more comments saying, you know, oh, it's not that.
It's not a dog accent.
Why?
It's what we said!
It's not.
You know that it's a Russian accent, or Italian accent, or Canadian accent, or British accent, or French accent.
Or, uh, we've even heard that
Ooh accent!
We weren't so sure about the last one though.
So like, we obviously heard like, French.
Yeah, yeah.
Right?
But ooh, I don't know where that one comes from.
But we searched it up, and we found out that Kobo-senpai sometimes likes to put on like a ooh accent for fun.
Right?
Yeah.
Right.
I don't know what it- what it-
Is it fun?
Kobo-senpai, is it fun?
It's very cute though, but no!
It's not that.
It's just us.
It's just how we are.
You know, sometimes we say funny things or make mistakes.
Mistakes.
We don't really think of it like that.
It's not really a mistake.
It's just us being who we are.
FUWAMOCO Morning!
I don't know.
Ruffians, you say the Ruffians.
But, you know, I don't know.
I think maybe it happens when I'm feeling more comfy and relaxed, you know?
So, right now I'm not relaxed!
Because Ruffians are Ruffians!
Right.
But Moco-chan, sometimes you, like, unnecessarily, like, sound to the end.
Why do you mean?
That sounds weird.
I don't, I don't,
I don't think I really feel it.
I don't really know what this is.
So I don't think it's really there, but... I feel like you're just being silly, huh, Ruffians?
But, regardless!
This is just how we are, okay?
So Ruffians!
Whether you say things a bit differently than others, or have an accent, we want you to embrace that, okay?
It's what makes you, you!
And it's beautiful!
Don't be shy about it.
And we won't be either, okay?
Got it!
Misunderstanding done.
BAU BAU!
No more questions.
We aren't taking any more questions.
But, well, that's a lie.
We still are taking questions, right, Moco-chan?
We are.
Yeah, it's okay.
Yeah.
Wow!
Ruffians!
It's the beginning of a new, new, beautiful, brand new week.
And with the start of every week,
It's time to challenge ourselves to something new.
I would say that Moco-chan, you're going to be challenging yourself to something new, but it's not really new at this point anymore, huh?
But Moco-chan wants to overcome her fear.
It's not a fear of natto.
You know, natto is really good for you.
It's really healthy.
It's worthwhile doing this.
I feel like it's supposed to be healthy, but now I feel like the stress is maybe not healthy anymore.
Well, today we're going to continue the challenge.
So, Ruffians, there might be some Ruffians that still don't know what natto is.
That is okay.
You get to learn natto!
I wonder how many Ruffians learn what natto is through this challenge.
That would be interesting to find out.
But natto is a fermented soybean.
And it's really popular as a Japanese breakfast food.
But it can be rather sticky and slimy and a bit strong smelling.
Difficult.
Yeah.
to eat, but it is really really healthy for you and I want Moco-chan to be able to do BAU BAU for a long time.
That's a good!
So that's why you're gonna challenge yourself and eat tomato today, right?
But Moco-chan, how are you feeling today though?
As I stir it up.
Not.
Not into challenging myself.
Why?
It's a new week, Moco-chan.
Yeah, but- You could've set a good example for the Ruffians.
I don't know.
Maybe it's just me, but I want to choose when I challenge it.
And I don't feel like it now.
I never feel like it.
One day's the day.
It's a new week.
Not all Fridays.
I feel like if I use my brain, it's just an excuse, because you know, when a challenge comes your way, you can't be like, oh, I'm not ready for it.
Waffle, it's ready for Moco-chan!
Wait, I don't have a tissue.
Oh no.
I don't have tea!
But Moco-chan, I did do something nice.
I brought you soy sauce.
Do you want some soy sauce on it?
Can I pour soy sauce on the one bean?
No!
It's gonna get everywhere.
The poi soy sauce is not- Poi?
It's not gonna go on at all.
The poi!
I'm gonna put the soy sauce all over it, okay?
Okay.
Not too much.
There you go!
That's a good amount.
I'm gonna stir it a bit more.
The flavor is gonna be really strong.
You don't need to work that hard for it.
The soy sauce is becoming friends with the soybeans.
They're soy happy!
Whoa!
It got really... What's wrong?
Why are you screaming?
It got really strong smelling all of a sudden.
Because you screamed, the Ruffians didn't hear it when I said they're soy happy.
This looks good!
The stings are extra stingy today.
Oh, that's worse.
No, it's good!
It's worse.
It's good.
Okay, Moco-chan!
I'm hungry.
At least I have my chopsticks.
It looks really good.
It smells really good.
Hello!
Moco-chan is going to eat natto!
In 3, 2, 1...
That's right, we can't count down yet!
Moco-chan, first, before you eat it, you have to say thank you to the farmers in Kochi.
They worked hard.
I don't know if that has much feeling in it.
You're just mumbling it.
Okay, Moco-chan, you're just gonna start with one bean, but after that you're gonna eat another one.
It looks really good.
The color is a bit darker this time because of the soy sauce.
They're extra shiny.
Not so fluffy, but shiny.
It's like natto performing on stage, you know?
It's doing its best.
This is the moment where it's going to shine the most.
Be the brightest, you know?
You can see it's working so hard.
The farmers worked so hard to produce them.
Super silly.
I know.
Now it's ready.
It's that moment.
Right.
They're shining.
I want to be able to eat it so that I can enjoy it, you know?
Because I don't want to just be like, ah, I'm overdoing it.
I don't want to just be pushing myself really hard to be able to eat it.
I want to be able to eat it and enjoy it.
No, but I want to be able to enjoy it.
Be like, ah, I'm woken up, I want to eat.
I actually really do thank the farmers in Tochigi.
That's how I want to feel.
Okay, Moco-chan, you're gonna have to eat it because I'm really hungry.
Let's finish up, Moco-chan.
I'm hungry, but I don't want to eat this!
It makes me feel the opposite of hungry.
Okay, Moco-chan, we're gonna count down from five.
Five!
Four!
Three!
Two!
One!
It's in my mouth.
It's on my tongue.
She's kind of attempting at chewing, like she doesn't know how to chew.
Oh, it's stuck to her tooth!
What are you gonna do, Moco-chan?
Are you even trying to eat food?
That's not how you eat food.
Just did not eat it at all.
That was barely in there.
Moco-chan, do you need me to be an example?
No?
Cough drop!
I'm actually proud though, maybe you improved Moco-chan because you didn't ask for water.
I just got a cough drop and it's more flavor.
I wanna eat it.
Ruffian natto is so yummy.
The flavor is too strong, the natto.
I feel like the soy sauce made it too strong.
Is it okay if I eat it all right now?
It improved the flavor in the wrong direction.
It's so yummy!
Moco-chan, watch me carefully, okay?
I like eating aijiki beans.
Moco-chan, are you watching?
No, I don't care.
Natto Masta.
Mokugoe.
Definitely.
It's so yummy!
Give me one moment, there's about two bites left.
Is this what FUWAMOCO Morning has come down to?
We're just gonna... eat.
I'm hungry.
We're just gonna eat now, hai.
The farmers of Tochigi make too yummy natto.
Oh, it's their fault, hai.
We're gonna blame it on them now.
Fuwawa is gaming.
No, she's eating.
Moco-chan, you're watching?
No.
So, so strong.
You done?
You good?
ASMR, please don't listen to Fuwawa chewing!
No.
Only listen to it.
I'm done!
Gochisousama deshita!
It was so yummy!
Moco-chan, you have to chew slowly so you can taste them.
I don't want to taste it.
Avoid my tears.
Good job, Fuwawa!
Thank you, you didn't need to say so much.
What about thank you, Mococo?
Well...
I feel like... I have the strength to give you one more minute.
But Moco-chan, I don't know.
I feel like at the end of every challenge I want to compliment you.
You shouldn't compliment me.
You tried, Mococo.
Thank you.
What's important is that I tried.
I didn't want to, but I did.
It didn't go well, but I tried, okay?
So that deserves praise.
Right.
That was an attempt.
That's good.
You know, you didn't feel like it, but you overcame those feelings.
I tried it.
I guess that's good.
Good job, Moco-chan.
BAU BAU!
Now, for our Doggie of the Day, we have... De-den!
The Doggie of the Day is a teen!
Moco-chan, do you ever feel so defeated in Donkey Kong Country that maybe you feel like giving a little lick to the controller too?
Maybe.
I feel a lot of stuff, huh?
I don't want to lick the controller.
Why?
Because your hands have been on it.
Just the top part.
The top part?
The top part.
Well, you licked the Switch cartridge, right?
So... I didn't do that.
You did.
We should try licking all the hardware.
Gaming hardware.
Maybe not.
Especially not after eating natto, no.
No?
Yeah.
Wow.
You know, Athena might like giving a lick to the controller sometimes too, but she also really likes naps and hikes.
Very healthy.
I like licking the controller.
It's a very healthy combo.
Very big sub for licking the controller, right?
FUWAMOCO, we haven't really gone on many hikes before, but we also, we like, instead of naps, we like big sleeps.
Big naps!
And we like long walks.
So it's kind of similar, right?
Athena also likes broccoli.
Broccoli is good.
That's a good choice, right?
Broccoli is yummy.
I feel like we could be good friends together, you know?
But broccoli is the best when it's not raw.
Raw-ish.
What do you think, Ruffians?
That's kind of weird.
What?
Licking broccoli is weird, Ruffians.
It's yum.
Vegetables yum.
BAU!
BAU BAU!
Hi, Ruffians!
I think you've been going on lots of walks, right?
Thank you!
Thank you for stretching those paws.
Getting out there even though it's a bit cold.
Well, Ruffians, where were we out and about this time?
Ni hao, de-den!
Is this the gate to the Northwest Passage?
I mean, it sure looks like it could be it, but... Sorry, it's not.
The way that we can tell this isn't actually it though, because the only way you can actually get to the Northwest Passage is you have to enter in first from the Maka.
Yeah.
Yeah, you can't go human world to Northwest Passage.
It's not p-p-possible.
P-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-possible.
Yeah, it's pretty tricky.
Travel's a little takes a while.
It takes a little bit, you know.
It makes travel a bit of a headache.
So, first you'll need to find your way to the Makai, okay?
And then from there, you have to make sure to take the right gate to the Northwest Passage, okay?
It's not as obvious as this, and you know there isn't text on it, but we can tell you one thing!
It's definitely more impressive than that.
Yeah, it's pretty cool.
It's pretty cool.
Yeah.
Not obvious, but more impressive.
You'll know it from the feeling it makes you feel when you look at it.
Yeah.
But, uh, well... Good luck on your search for the... Yeah!
...the gate to the Northwest Passage.
But, uh... Praise Makai.
Yeah, I've had a feeling you might be walking for quite a while.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
That'll be good for a couple walks though, huh?
More than a couple, I think.
Maybe a lifetime of walks.
More than a lifetime.
And for our question of the day, we have... We're still taking questions.
We have... De-den!
Hello FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
So I recently saw you both at Anime NYC, the Q&A, but I got scared to ask a question because of stage fright.
Don't worry, don't worry.
So my question is, how do you deal with public speaking?
Good question.
This is a very good question, yeah.
I feel like, you know, the number one way to help with that kind of shaky feeling that you get before you're going to go in front of a large audience.
Or your tummy hurts.
The number one way is practice.
Probably practice, you know?
Having a clear image of what you want to do or what you want to say helps a lot, I know.
But we very much understand.
I think if it was us in your position,
It's very nerve-wracking.
Right, right.
And then like, this is the what-ifs.
Like, what if the microphone doesn't work?
Or, you know, those kind of things.
That makes it very, very scary.
But please don't worry though.
We're very, very happy to answer your questions.
I wish we could answer more questions.
You know, if somehow, somehow, you kinda get all tongue-tied like FUWAMOCO does and it kinda gets jumbled all up, don't worry because we'll help you.
We've been there too, so.
I think though, if...
Something happens and you just have to remember that even if things end up like the worst case scenario for you, in the end, it doesn't really matter too much, okay?
Everyone will forget and maybe they won't even notice.
Just take it in stride, okay?
Because you have a long life with lots of successes and lots of failures.
So just take it easy, okay?
Exactly.
BAU BAU!
If anything, I want to talk more, so don't feel too nervous to talk because that makes me sad.
Don't say it's my dog when it's not your dog.
Be truthful.
And questions too!
And Pero Sightings.
Please let us know with the hashtag!
Hashtag!
FWMCMORNING!
BAU BAU!
And for our next stream!
We have another stream today!
We have de-den!
Holosuika!
We're going to be playing Holosuika.
You might have heard.
There was a big update.
And now, not only are Ien-senpai and ID-senpai included, but FUWAMOCO!
We're there too!
We're in it!
So we're going to be making a lot of
Small Moco-chan and big Fuwawas.
I want to try a whole bunch of different play styles.
Last time I tried to get a top score, but I kind of have an idea for something else too, so we'll have to see.
Please join us, Ruffians.
You can play along too because you can play right now on a web browser or browser phone.
It's really fun, so please check it out.
BAU BAU!
And our schedule!
We have a brand new schedule!
Not only is FUWAMOCO Morning episode 50 this week, the very next episode, but we're gonna be doing our best to finish off Metal Gear Solid and...
Donkey Kong Country.
I don't know.
Ruffians, you keep on saying it's going to be tricky for us, but we're already on disc two of Metal Gear Solid.
So I'm pretty confident.
And then Donkey Kong Country.
I don't know.
I think we only have a couple stages left, you know?
So why are you saying it's going to be final part one?
Why?
The boss is going to be tricky.
Well, we've never played against the boss.
Two discs for one game?
Yeah!
We'll play the PlayStation 1, so... They're like that sometimes.
But we hope you'll join us as we finish Metal Gear Solid and Donkey Kong Country, which was a game we started at debut, kind of like.
Yeah!
We'll be very happy.
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for tweeting us today for FUWAMOCO Morning, our last episode before we go to our 50th episode.
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much!
Before we say BAU BAU for now,
I'd like to shout out to some of our extra special Ruffians today!
Lucky fives!
BAU BAU!
Put it up!
Cheeseburger!
BAU BAU!
Sammy!
Maina!
BAU BAU!
Back split!
Dog Salmon.
BAU BAU!
Shunko.
Angus.
BAU BAU!
Kintaro Ui.
Ikaike.
BAU BAU!
Torch.
To every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!